[Musique]
un couple et leur ami accusé d'avoir
séquestré et torturé des jeunes filles
dans un pavillon d'apoignny en 1984 sont
actuellement jugés devant la Cour
d'Assise
d'osser secrétaire général de
l'association pour adultes et jeunes
handicapés il aurait violé régulièrement
depuis 1 an une jeune handicapée mentale
de 23
ans un pêcheur a découvert ce matin dans
Lyonne à osser le cadavre entièrement
dénudé d'une jeune Anglaise de 20
ans bonsoir affairire douloureusees
difficile à tentere pour une famille la
disparition d'Abel la ville âgée de 17
ans près d'osser est toujours
inexpliqué depuis dizaines d'années
quatre jeunes filles déficientes mental
ayant transité par cette institution
reste toujours porté disparu peut-on
continuer à cautionner par notre silence
cette situation c'est l'histoire d'une
région c'est l'histoire d'un pays et de
son rapport aux jeunes femmes
handicapées au pupit de la nation et aux
petites gens qui ne sont rien face à
l'institution on se rend compte qu'à
l'époque dans la région il y a beaucoup
d'affaires non résolu disparition
volontaire affaires criminelles on a que
des rumeurs et en tout cas
officiellement aucun dossier aucune
instruction n'est ouverte pour
rechercher les causes de la disparition
de ces se jeunes femmes nétait rien pour
la société au fond et la disparition de
rien ça n'inquiète
personne quand les enquêtes
disfonctionnent quand la justice
disfonctionne et bien on a des tueurs
qui passent au travers des mailles du
filet c'est naturel et c'est normal on
sait maintenant que tro tueurs en série
se sont croisés dans
Lyonne moi je me retrouve face un tuur
en série mais sans sans y croire je me
dis que cet Émile Louis peut être tuur
en série enfin mais en tout cas c'est la
dernière chose qui me reste à faire
finalement c'est aller lui poser la
question on vient vous voir je suis
journaliste et j'aimerais discuter avec
vous si
c'est encore cette affaire là foutez-moi
la p ça ave plus de 20 ans ouais alors
qu'est-ce qu'on vient de faire chier
encore
là
attendez il y aémission à la télé là
avec l'utre con comment s'it
[Musique]
oui ser all pouro pour dire que j suis
pour r
arrêtepon de m'accuser de mcus
sur é là SAF
moi
[Musique]
je me souviens ça vaêtre début octobre
96 je décroche le téléphone pour appeler
ilouis
quoi
Monsieur Louis voilà jeelle Stéphan ma
je travaille à TF1 ah c'est vous qui
dites du mal de moi à la télé depuis des
mois il serait bien temps que vous
m'écoutiez ok c'est bon on y
va et j'y vais avec frédéricard de de
VSD on dit on va faire le cou
[Musique]
ensemble on y va sans caméra parce que
c'était la première fois et que peu de
chance
queouis n laisse laisse le
filmer si on doit arriver les midi on se
regarde un peu comme de de couillons en
se disant on va vraiment aller voir un
type pareil enfin un type qu'on supsonne
des tuur en on y va et on y
va on frappe à la porte et puis y a ce
vieux monsieur là qui nous
ouvre et puis bah on s'ass voilà comme
ça dans le canapé il se met en face de
nous
l'ambiance un peu un peu surréaliste et
puis commence à lui poser des
question et on va lui mettre pendant 3
He tous les arguments possibles et
imaginables en face de lui à tel endroit
à tel moment vous étiez là mais
reconnaissez on lui sort tous les
détails de l'affaire tout ce qu'on
connaît précisément à ce
momentl c'est pas moi c'est un coup
monté c'est machin celui-là il m'aimait
pas
et puis peu à peu il y a des petites
choses un peu bizarres qui commence à
apparaître comme le gars est malgré tout
assez content de lui il commence à dire
oui qu'il a qu'il a pu avoir des
relations sexuelles avec les unes et les
autres on sent quand même une espèce de
malaise quoi voilà ce vieux monsieur là
qui n qui nous parle de ses relations
très ambigu avec des handicapés de 17
ans au bout de 3 He on a fait le tour
moi je suis pas la justice je suis pas
la police je peux pas le mettre en garde
à vue le mec donc bah merci Monsieur au
revoir on sort avec la sensation que bah
que l'affaire est pas finie et que ce
type là il faut pas le
[Musique]
lâcher
comment vous vivez aujourd'hui comment
je vis mais je suis bien dans
ma je suis heureux avec ma femme mais
j'en ai marre qu'bien de me faire ch je
avec
ça
toujours m'emder ces histoires là je
suis la btoire je suis pas une btoire je
je pas un criminel je pas un assassin
c'est je vous dire pas plus qu'un
violeur et encore Mo
[Musique]
pédophile je m'appelle Frédéric veard je
suis journaliste et j'ai couvert
l'affaire des dispar lion pour VSD puis
le
Parisien moi je suis à la fois jeune
journaliste je bosse dans un magazine
qui est plutôt un magazine
outsider Stéphane Maquin a sollicité des
médias nationaux et il trouve pas
effectivement beaucoup
d'écho écoute on va ou on va travailler
ensemble ça m'intéresse et donc je suis
parti pour la première fois au
ser je retrouve noir et pierre gonzalz
de
Gaspar ils attendent un maximum de de
soutien médiatique et donc ils vont
réussir comme ça embarquer quelques
quelques journalistes dans
l'affaire dès que la cour d'appel de
Paris a demandé d'instruire bah là tout
le monde s'engouffrait c'est on a eu
tous les médias quasiment journellement
et puis il y avait des des choses qui
sortait il y avait des fuites il y avait
des investigations qui étaient
faites
de toute façon il y avait des
disparitions qui étaient là comment
elles avaient disparu c'était important
de
[Musique]
savoir je suis vigoureux je suis grand
reporter à l'OPS j'ai travaillé pendant
10 ans sur l'affaire des disparus de
lion d'abord au journal du dimanche puis
au Nouvel
[Musique]
Observateur j'ai des souvenirs de
Lyonne
gris toujours une espèce de ciel
bas je me souviens j'avais aussi
beaucoup de difficultés pour que les
gens me parle en fait j'y allais
beaucoup mais je revenais souvent les
mains
vides je me souviens d'avoir pas mal Eré
en
fait je cherchais les ambiances de ce
qu'avait pu vivre les victimes et je
cherchais les ambiances des centres qui
étaient
visés et en fait je trouvais rien je
trouvais que des portes
closes
je me rends compte maintenant que
l'ambiance que je trouvais c'était
l'ambiance qui calfutrait en fait tout
ce passé qu'on voulait pas
voir les familles reprèent d'espoir bien
évidemment tout en ayant le la
conviction que malheureusement leur leur
sœur avait été tué espoir au moins de
découvrir la vérité et de savoir ce qui
était devenu leur
s l'c é ouverte confié un juge auxeroir
qui s'appelle beno
Lewandowski un juge assez inexpérimenté
qui commence à faire travailler les les
gendarmes
d'xer 20 ans après le voile se lève sur
l'affaire des disparus de Lyonne c'est
au petit matin que le juge d'instruction
le procureur de la République et les
gendarmes ont commencé les fouilles oui
on a trouvé ce matin un petit morceau
d'os dont l'origine et la nature sont
momentanément inconnu et difficiles à
connaître comme ça sur une première
vision et puis un morceau de plastique
qui semble être un morceau de semelle je
trouve quand même que l'enquête elle a
piétiné trop longtemps oui c vrai hein
çait trop long on a fait tout un cinéma
hein et ben c'est inadmissible et des
handicapés qui gaient alors profiter des
handicapés mais je trouve que la justice
n pas été très rapide he peu après on
retrouve un deuxième morceau d'os et
l'autre semelle correspondant
vraisemblablement à un pied de jeune
femm ils font des fouilles il se trouve
que ce sont des EAU d'animaux et donc là
tout le monde rigole
vous voyez bien ça c'est pas sérieux
cette affaire là il y a pas il y a pas
d'affaire donc là tout le monde pense
que ça va s'arrêter mais Pierre insiste
lâche pas l'affaire il ils vont même
jusqu'au ministère de la Justice pour
dire non mais c'est pas possible
l'enquête faut pas la faire comme ça et
cetera et donc la décision est prise par
le juge de saisir effectivement la
section de recherche de
Paris leur mission est très claire c'est
bah tant qu'éiloui n'est pas en garde à
vue euh vous vous lâchez pas voilà vous
êtes à 100 %
là-dessus je m'appelle Éric Barou
j'étais enquêteur à la section de
recherche de Paris nous avons été saisis
par le le juge levandovski le 18
novembre
97 quand on est saisi par le magistrat
instructeur on a très très peu
d'éléments on a les auditions et les
investigations qui ont déjà été menées
depuis que lag des recherches de ser et
saisi et on a quelques documents
manuscrits de jeanbert on a les se
n il nous explique un petit peu le
dossier et éventuellement il y a un
chauffeur de bus qui pourrait être
impliqué dans
l'affaire ça vous faisait pas bizarre de
plus voir ces F là bah on dire elles ont
fugué elles ont fugué ah qui c'est qui
vous disait qu' qu' av bah les gens les
gens les il disait que qu'ell s'est
sauvé les responsables du imou
non pr toutes sortes de gens hein
ouais les gendarmes ils vont d'abord
faire ce que le travail qui aurait dû
être fait à l'époque dans les années 70
c'estàdire s'assurer que ces jeunes
filles n'était pas en
fugue ça fait 25 ans qu'elles ont
disparu approximativement on a commencé
nos propres investigations à chercher
toutes les familles des jeunes filles
disparues la plupart des jeunes filles
ont été placées ou dans des institutions
ou dans des familles d'accueil donc ça
ça a déjà été très très
compliqué
on est des enfants de la DAS ma sœur mon
frère et
moi-même nous avons été placés dans une
famille d'accueil qui était gardien d'un
château à ville sargeot qui était la
famille
Louis j'avais 12
ans donc j'y suis resté un an mon frère
il est resté quelques semaines quelques
mois je crois ma sœur y est resté plus
longtemps
elle
ah Jacqueline c'était c'était c'était
une
fille très gentille très douce
elle savait lire elle savait écrire elle
pouvait prendre de train toute seule
elle pouvait faire des choses toute
seule mais bon voilà elle avait des
lacunes sur pas mal de choses mais elle
était légèrement déficiente
oui ben c'était une vie sympa hein on
vivait dans un château il y avait un
pigeonnier il y avait des grandes allées
il y avait une forêt derrière on pouvait
faire plein de choses c'était plutôt
très agréable il y avait un étan on
pouvait pêcher
ilouis j'avais mes yeux d'enfant c'était
un monsieur rondouillard les cheveux
gris des bonnes joues bien rouges une
grosse voix qui portait quand
même qui était très très dur avec ses
certains de ses enfants et moins avec
d'autres mais pour ma part tout se
passait bien dire il a jamais eu de il a
jamais eu de violence exercé sur moi ni
de gifle ni de coup de pied ni rien du
tout donc moi je m'amusais comme un
comme un mom oh
[Musique]
là en fait je prends conscience que ma
sœur disparu lorsque j'ai assisté à
l'émission perdue de vue pour la
première fois et qu'on soupçonnait très
fortement Monsieur émil
Louis la dernière fois on a vu ma sœur
ce monsieur devait l'emmener dans une
petite ville avoisinante à Vallon dans
un travail où elle devait qu'elle devait
effectuer
là-bas puis là ben là c'est tout s'est
effondré d'un coup je savais que tous
mes petits rêves que je m'étais battis
pendant toutes ces années tomber par
terre que ma sœur n'était pas quelque
part avec des enfants heureus de vivre
je je savais qu'il lu était arrivé
quelque chose finalement et donc j'ai é
gérant salarié à l'époque et puis bah
tout s'est effondré sous mes pieds je
j'ai quitté mon emploi parce que je
n'arrivais plus à l'assumé je donc je me
suis rendu aux émissions je me suis
porté parti civile et puis
voilà quand nous sommes saisis comme
tout enquêteur on ouvre plusieurs pistes
pour ne pas qu'on nous reproche à un
moment donné d'avoir travaillé que sur
une seule piste je pense que je dois
être le premier à être entendu par la SR
et je file l'intégralité du dossier mais
j'ai pas les
preuves donc effectivement la pisteoui
avait déjà été ouverte par janbert par
les enquêteurs de la BR donc cette piste
là on l'a gardé on a travaillé mais nous
en même temps on a ouvert la piste sur
un trafic d'êtres humains éventuellement
sur la prostitution puisque on avait
entendu parler de l'affaire
d'unean et au fur et à mesure de ces 3
années et des investigations qu'oné sur
chacune de nos pistes les portes se sont
fermées pour en avoir plus qu'une
[Musique]
celle trouver des preuves des éléments
matériels qui permettent d'aller
chercher ouis de le placer en gardévue
et de le confronter à des à des éléments
et ça c'était plus compliqué parce que
20 an après comment
faire il n'y aura jamais de preu contre
émil Louis je veux dire on a un faisceau
de présomption phénoménal il est à
chaque fois présent mais on n pas une
[__] de
preuve
après le passage à l'émission perdue de
vue pour la première
fois madame de La m'a téléphoné en me
disant queou avait fait des choses
terribles mais qu'elle ne pouvait pas en
parler parce qu'elle avait peur pour ses
enfants
voilà c'est comme si elle me demandait
pardon finalement pour pour
Jacqueline
tout le monde me disait que c'était une
ambiance qui permettait que Émile Louis
agisse comme il agit pour moi le mystère
il était là c'est comment c'était
possible de tout savoir et en même temps
de de rien vouloir voir
quoi effectivement il y a des services
qui traînent les pieds sans citer la
page sans citer monsieur de cupè qui a
traîné les pieds pour nous donner les
dossiers des différentes jeunes filles
ils ont pas fait attention ils ont rien
vu ils ont pas été prévenus de choses
voilà il savent
rien c'était pas possible de se dire que
sur un espace géographique si petit il y
a autant de choses qui se produisent qui
sont dramatiques et qu'on voit pas donc
il y avait forcément un
problème
[Musique]
on était certain de de le mettre à un
moment donné en garde à vue mais il
fallait quand même que nous nous ayons
différents éléments pour pouvoir lui
poser des
questions on se rend compte avec Pierre
maunoir qu'on a peu de retour sur cette
enquête nous avons fourni beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments à la justice
beaucoup de témoignages beaucoup de
documents nous avions des lettres nous
avions des preuves qui appartenaient aux
victimes mais qui n'avaient pas été
demandé par les les enquêteurs je me
suis dit à l'époque que faire intervenir
un enquêteur qui allait parler aux
autres enquêteurs valoriser nos
arguments ça pouvait être un
atout nous connaissions Jean-François
gral et nous savions qu'il venait de
quitter la
gendarmerie vous espérez vraiment
trouver quelque chose
ici quit à vérifier il faut vérifier
jusqu'au bout parce que ça çarive
fréquemment de trouver justement
d'arriver à à découvrir un indice là où
on imagine
pas je m'appelle Samuel luret je suis
journaliste et j'ai réalisé en 2000 le
film détective contre tuur en
série l'idée c'était vraiment de suivre
le travail d'un détectif privé qui avait
été quand même un des CAD adors de la
gendarmerie
[Musique]
nationale donc l'idée c'était d'un côté
que Jean-François abgral nous serve de
lien avec la gendarmerie la section de
recherche de Paris qu' transmettent les
éléments que nous avions directement
puisquonarrivait pas à aller assez vite
sur l'instruction avec le juge
d'instruction et le deuxième aspect
c'était de revérifier des éléments dont
nous disposions mais de les remettre
dans leur contexte de peut-être les
compléter
quand Jean-François s'est emparé du
dossier une des premières choses qu'il a
décidé de faire c'est d'aller entendre
les familles des
victime
d'expérience il sait que il y a toujours
quelque chose à aller chercher à
rediscuter
entrez
m lou vous en avez entendu parler mais
oui mais oui on lu a don bon Dieu sans
confession à
celi-l comment vous l'avez rencontré
ilen il amené ma fille ma fille chez la
logeuse c'est comme ça que j'ai connu
voilà comme ça j'ai connu puis m'a écrit
lettre et l'histoire de la lettre elle
arrive comme ça oui la lettre donc vous
l'avez vous l'avez déjà montré à
quelqu'un non je dis non j'ai jamais
montré gardé pour moi à qui vous voulez
que je la monre d'accord ça c'est le
courrier que vous avez reçu oui bah de
de lui là de ça c'est la lettre ce
document en fait est révélateur à
plusieurs titres de la personnalité
d'Émil Louis d'abord il est daté donc on
a une référence il y a une référence
temporel hein juste quelques semaines
avant les disparitions euh et puis les
points importants sont bah la
manipulation qui apparaît là on fixe une
fausse adresse pour un rendez-vous qui
doit garder secret en prenant bien garde
de ne pas prévenir Madame maudier qui
est la nource d'accueil de Chantal donc
là déjà en quelques lignes on a un bout
de la personnalité de
l'auteur Jean-François Abgal il s'est
attaché à comprendre le profil
psychologique du
personnage comprendre comment le tueur
fonctionne comme comment il approche ses
victimes comment il met en scène ses
meurtres comment il les camoufle
comprendre ça c'est être au cœur de de
la personnalité du tueur il a été dans
la tête du
[Musique]
tueur Mar c'est la filleée
desou
sa mère en fait avait dit à maline
écoute il y a dans le garage de la
maison une valise ce sont des affaires
que ton père a oublié une valise qu' a
cherché à récupérer plusieurs
fois on a cherché et on a trouvé des
vêtements que qu'elle ne reconnaissait
pas et que je ne reconnaissais pas non
plus c'était uniquement des effets
féminins qui moi me paraissaient quand
même passer d'un autre temps quand même
des truc bah que que moi je n'aurais
jamais porté elle m'a dit je savais bien
qu'un jour ou l'autre de toute façon ça
arriverait moi j'étais persuadé quand
même que ça avait quelque chose à voir
avec la disparition de ces jeunes femmes
hein
[Musique]
euh si on retrouve des ADN sur ces
vêtements mais sur quel vêtement qu'on a
trouvé dans la dans le garage bah je
vous dis ça peut ça peut être ma femme
décédée qui mon ex FME décédée qui les
amis se jackine vest mais autrement il y
avait per de personne d'autre ou alors
des bonns de gosse ou des ou des des
gants de de gosse qui laissé dans le cas
c'est tout
ouais dans cette valise en fait il y
avait des vêtements féminins qui vont
être donc récupérés par les gendarmes
sur lequel on va chercher de l'ADN et
cetera et cetera on va rien trouver
parce que la police scientifique à
l'époque peut-être
pas aussi performante qu'aujourd'hui euh
mais ce qui va être décisif c'est que il
y a l'un des mteaux qui va être reconnu
par la la famille de Madeleine dejus qui
est une des
disparu là il y avait un élément qui
relié Émile Louis à une
disparu quand Jean-François se replonge
dans le dossier il s'aperçoit que
Louis a été condamné deux fois et
notamment dans le Var en récidive pour
agression sexuelle sur
mineur
là nous on est en 2000 les fait date de
89 et donc un enquêteur qu'il est il
descend dans le Var pour aller
interviewer un des parents des des
petites
[Musique]
victimes
m'a bien vu là il m'a bien il m'a bien d
en erreur il m moi j'ai eu confiance
pour faire un gars comme ça était
d'apparence gentil jovial alors c'est là
pour moi je dis ça Ren ce mec là est-ce
que vous pouvez me donner exactement la
tenur de ses propos qu- qu'est-ce qu'il
vous disait sur les femmes en fait donc
il fallait carrément
les je veux dire les les VI oler les
trucs comme ça c'est c'est éta faire mal
à la personne et comme je vous dis
admettant il vourait la fouetter la
fouette il apprenait de force et puis
après il pouvait la laisser crever il en
avait rien à [__] voà c'est c'est seul
détail que je peux vous
donner là encore il va accumuler des
éléments qui permettent de dessiner
toujours de façon plus précise la façon
dont pense d' Louis c'est c'est lui qui
me raconta ça ah ouais moi je lui dit je
l'ai dit mais tu l' fait ce que vous
raconte là il m'a dit oui je l'ai déjà
fait après vous êtes doxer vous êtes
parti où ici directement vous êtes non
vous êtes allé au camping oui la
régionob ou il y a une histoire
làbas
non
[Musique]
à l'époque dans le Varille émil Louis a
des fréquentations de jeunes femmes dans
du camping notamment une jeune femme qui
est juste en face de sa caravane jeune
femme qui est découverte un matin
inanimé le médecin qui se présente sur
les lieux déclare qu'il s'agit d'une
mort
naturelle je pense que c'est pas une
mort qui est très très naturelle et que
éventuellement on aurait pu lui poser
certaines
[Musique]
questions vous vivez toujours dans le
doute en fait oui on vivra toujours dans
le doute il y a personne qui viendra me
dire la
vérité on vous
dit moi pendant un moment j'ai cru
qu'elle éta qu'elle était morte d'une
maladie ça m'avait soulagé quand j'étais
tranquille je pouvais faire son deuil
reviens on me dit
[Musique]
non il y a trop
de trop d'histoire où il a été o partout
où il a habité partout o il a fait du
mal pourquoi il aurait laissé ma mère
tranquille dans le Midi on M demander de
ne pas aller là-bas parce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup peur que je puisse aller faire
des enquêtes
là-bas on n pas voulu enquêter sur son
parcours criminel après Lyonne quand il
est
parti dans le sud on a essayé de
ressortir le dossier mais on n pas voulu
nous permettre de le faire donc je je
pense qu'on ne sait pas tout loin de làà
du parcours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
desmoui
[Musique]
vous avez fait combien de prison
pour 2
ans vous êtes chez
vousù bienvenue à Casabianda prison les
pieds dans l'eau avec vue imprenable sur
les rivages de l'Italie un centre de
détention sans mur sans barreaux sans
verrou presque sans
gardien
[Musique]
vous êtes ah nous sommes
bariés 92 he chéri ou oui et ici comment
ça se passe ça va très bien les gosses
il viennent chez moi voyez les des fois
il vient manger là ça c'est toujours
trava
[Musique]
pensé alors ma première rencontre avec
émil Louis on est en septembre 2000 ça
fait déjà des mois que je suis
jean-françoisgal dans son enquête je
connais suffisamment le
dossier pour me dire que le moment est
venu maintenant pour aller recueillir la
parole de celui qui reste à ce moment-là
toujours le suspect numéro
l'accueil il est dans le
film on vient vous voir je suis
journaliste j'aimerais discuter avec
vous si non non éoute Caire foutez-moi
la ça parce que moi je commence à en
avoir ça fait plus de 20 ans qu'estce
qu'on vient de faire chier encore là
surout avec çave ça moi je dis
franchement je me pr mon je vous fout un
cou pas pe
de vousz pas raison deout coup d'
pasressen et puis dans le fond on sent
que il est quand même très intrigué
c'est un homme qui a malgré tout besoin
de savoir ce qui se passe autour de de
l'affaire qui le
concerne je n'en tire si je puis dire
pas
grand-chose je suis marié je suis
tranquille je suis heureux alors qu'
fout la je suis heureux alors je qu'on
fout tout ça je ne veux plus quoi que ce
soit il va s'instaurer quand même sur
cette histoire quelque chose d'assez
particulier je pense que c'est l'affaire
les journalistes et les enquêteurs ont
travaillé le plus de
concerts
avec la presse il y a un échange
d'information je dirais même que les
journalistes sont souvent les meilleurs
enquêteurs c'est eux qui nous remontent
les meilleures
informations ce travail avec les
journalistes va être le secret de ce
dossier et la réussite de ce
dossieréit très limite on Savit tous par
rapport à la
procédure par rapport à notreontologie
parfois tout le monde se disait que
c'était le seul moyen d'avancer quoi
voilà cette stratégie là quand même qui
avait été élaboré par le colonel patin
ils sont dit très vite que pour faire
craqueroui pour l'amener à se découvrir
il fallait lui mettre une pression
médiatique
constante montrer que l'enquête se
poursuivait qu' serait jamais
[Musique]
tranquille la deème fois que je viens
voir il Louis on est en octobre la
machine médiatique c'est s remis en
marchees les disparu dans les environs
d' il y a plus de 20 ans
entre l'idée qui me passe par la tête
c'est de le filmer lui en train de se
regarder à la télévision c'est plus le
même homme que je découvre la deuxè fois
tout à coup l' se
resserre
pour une des images qui me vient de
tournage c'est c'est c'est de le voir
lui cette espèce de de masse un peu
recroquevillé sur lui-même tendu le dos
courbé enchaînant cigarette sur
cigarette se regardant sans un mot ou à
peine là je sens qu'il est
inqué ces vêtements appartiennent-ils au
disparus des expertises ADN sont en
cours pour le déterminerz B connaître
maintenant l'ADN et si l'ADN il y a rien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
alors c'est vrai qu'elle essaie de
donner le
change un peu de
désinvolture ils ont rien toute façon
c'est
prescrit donc on sent malgré tout tout
ce côté comme ça un
peu assuré que dans le fond c'est pas du
tout ce qu'il pense il est absolument
inquiet de la tournure des
choses ça c'est quelque chose que je
ressens très fort à ce momentl et qui va
dans dans le sens malgré tout de la
culpabilité c'était un phénomène c'était
quelque chose on pouvait interroger cet
homme accusé quand même de cette
disparition il y a des gens qu' qu' on
peur qu' on peur de vous ou quoi peur de
moi pourquoi donc peur de moi non je
sais pas alors non je suis pas méchant
pour
deessous on voit son comportement sa
parole ça s'exprimer sa façon de bouger
sa façon de se comporter aujourd'hui on
peut en parler on parlait pas à l'époque
mais oui moi j'avais fait un travail
avec les gendarmes je leur avais donné
les rush des journalistes on avait
travaillé avec des psychologues et des
psychiatres sur le comportement desoui
sur ces
images mais vous allez pisser le du mur
là un gamin j'ai vu saaquette ça
suffitédopile
quand je reviens on est en
novembre je sais que c'est la dernière
fois mon idée c'est de le faire parler
sur son enfance essayer de comprendre
l'homme si je puis dire derrière le
tuur qui me raconte ce jourl c'est qu'il
a été le témoin d'une scène
d'humiliation ces trois sœurs vont se
faire tondre à la
Libération pay é là le M regard ça comme
des bê sauvag comm des connards je dire
mon père j'avais discuté avec
lui
malheureusement ça vous fait mal cette
histoire
mon père 14 C de
guerreitaire blessé de fois de
fo0 les
remerciement il ne joue pas VO il nous a
obligé à nous mettre derrière lui veut
plus montrer il est voilà il est courbé
rentr
et pourtant là dans ce qu'il raconte on
sent que il y a quelque chose comme ça
qui vient des profondeurs qui le
submerge et il s'effondre et et moi-même
je je l'avoue il m'a
amuou
m'au le 11 décembre on descend sur Dr
Guignan on met tout en place et on
décide l'interpellation le 12 décembre
au matin
[Musique]